duas crianças brincavam no quintal uma
magrinha e uma gordinha pra vocês eu era
qual acertaram a gordinha e aí a gente
vinha correndo com calcinhas duda rica
feitas pela minha mãe eo meu pai que nos
ensinado previamente algumas poesias
dizia meninas declama poesia para as
visitas
a gente dava um passo à frente que dizia
de catulo da paixão cearense
a flor do maracujá maracujá foi banco eu
até posso afirmar mais branco do que a
coalhada mais lento do que o é quando as
flores brotavam nele lá pras bandas do
sertão o maracujá parecia união de
algodão
um dia faz muito tempo mês até não me
lembro
não sei se agosto setembro outubro
novembro
nosso senhor jesus cristo foi condenada
a morrer na cruz crucificado longe daqui
como que pregaram cristo a martelo por
ver tamanha proeza a natureza inteirinha
chorava de grande tristeza choravam as
flores no campo chorava até à figueira e
sabiá também chorava no olho da
laranjeira e o sangue de jesus cristo
sangue pisado de dor caía de goteiras
gota atingiu o pé da flor
e foi assim seu moço a história que ouvi
contar por que razão nasceu roxa
a flor do maracujá dedico esse texto
quando eu terminava poesia as visitas
batiam palma ea gente segurava no
barbalho na calcinha e fazer assim
dedico esta noite a meu pai everaldo
nunes essa parte esta fosse um ano atrás
ele estaria aqui para o wii que começou
a me preparar para esse dia quando eu
tinha seis anos de idade pai é pra você
é só falar de hoje
[Aplausos]
a pequena eu queria ser inteligente
perguntavam que você quer ser quando
crescer mesmo dizia médica dentista meu
irmão policial e eu dizia eu quero ser
uma menina inteligente mãe achava graça
as pessoas achavam graça a gordinha
pequenininha toda falante querendo ser
inteligente
quais foram as aprendizagens que eu
busquei adquirir na vida para realizar
meu sonho de não ser besta não ser
enganada pelo mundo
não me deixar levar pelos recados que
não necessariamente time campeão
eu comecei a prestar atenção nas lições
em casa
lembro que sentimos falta de água era um
lugar pobre escasso com muita poeira ea
gente tinha que ir para a água na bica
pai mandou fazer um tanque dividiu ao
meio um lado a gente botava água da bica
no outro água comprada água cara água
rara pai nos chamou ao lado do tanque e
nos disse
vou pedir uma coisa pra vocês agora a
gente pensou da economizar água porque
era cara era rara ele disse quem chegar
com um balde de primeira lição para ser
inteligente dar aquilo que me é caro e
nem é preciso seguir ouvindo tentando
entender mãe cuidadosa zelosa fazer
bolinhos de chuva para a gente levar
para a escola sinal de pobreza porque
nós não tínhamos o que levará o seu golo
de chuva que ela fazia para nós um sinal
de riqueza e aí a gente saía com esse
cuidado todo e ela dizia ao chegar na
casa das visitas tira sandália na porta
e não aceite nada que lhe foi oferecido
segunda lição querer dizer não porque o
princípio educativo passava por essa
negação e fui crescendo e um dia me
apresentar uma biblioteca
a gente é muito pobre uma família
carente pai policial mãe servente da
escola mas ele divide as enciclopédias
em 12 vezes era um ano pagando mas vale
a pena então disseram abriu a porta e
disse olha vocês não terão essa vocês
não tem fortuna vocês vão ter uma coisa
na vida
mento leão fiquei encantada pelos livros
por érico veríssimo por josé de alencar
fiquei louca por machado de assis tinha
receio de ler
jorge amado porque nas primeiras linhas
palavrões
eu sou de um tempo que gentil educado
não falava palavrão mas o que me
encantou mesmo foi a barra abrirá barça
como se eu estivesse mergulhando no
mundo e pensei com os conhecimentos que
o meu pai vem passando e as lições com a
educação e os modos que manhã vem
dizendo e com esse papel não ser burra
eu seria inteligente mas alguém me disse
que eu precisaria freqüentar a escola
porque os saberes adquiridos em casa não
dariam conta de dar conta do mundo e aí
eu fui pra escola o que a escola pra mim
primeiro a escola é um lugar depois a
escola é um lugar
depois a escola passa a ser um espaço de
disputa
por fim a escola é um terreno que me
ensina a ignorar o mundo
vamos primeiro espaço é um lugar a
escola é um lugar onde se ensina
disciplina
a escola é um lugar onde se transmitir o
conhecimento acumulado ao longo de
muitas gerações
a escola é o lugar que a gente aprendeu
na infância que era porta que era
estrada que era janela que eram os
espaços que abriria o mundo pra gente
que estrada a escola pode ser se no
momento que você traz passa o portão ela
te rompe ela te parte
ela ignora aquilo que você é para você
virar aquilo que ela deseja
a escola então é um lugar é o lugar da
negação de mim mesma é o lugar onde eu
tenho que me partir para acabei onde eu
tenho que me ignorar para dar certo onde
eu preciso me omiti para não ser vítima
da chacota
então eu era mais nova da sala não
ganhei cartilha a última semana
atribulada a caçula da sala
passei todo o primeiro ano sem cartilha
a escola era um lugar a mais gordinha
então é interessante que eu ficasse
sentado e quieta o que eu fosse no
mínimo muito inteligente muito esforçada
para que os apelidos corriqueiros aos
gordinhos não pairasse sobre mim
a escola é um lugar a partir do momento
que ela diz amy você menina e pobre não
pode sonhar porque os pobres não ficaram
sonhos ficaram trabalhos ea escola na
condição de não lugar daquele espaço que
nos ensina na porta da sala problemas
você deixa lá fora eu comecei a perceber
não imediatamente mas com os 20 anos de
docência
comecei a perceber que a escola era
aquilo que eduardo galeano grande poeta
latino americano que nos ensinou sobre a
nossa própria colonização que nos disse
que deveríamos ter cuidado com as
histórias que não eram contada em seu
livro dos abraços dentro de um texto
chamado paradoxos ele diz as escolas
como centro de ensino ensinam a ignorar
é nesse não lugar que eu resolvi existir
como profissional eu não queria
eu não queria ser professora eu queria
ser advogada eu queria ser jornalista
mas eu era pobre pobre na perspectiva
que se entende não ter recursos para
pagar os meus sonhos rica na perspectiva
de ter uma família cheia de teresa uma
biblioteca no quintal e conhecimentos
para comunicar as minhas ideias mas isso
não foi suficiente
na única escola particular da cidade
onde morava o e quando meu pai me pegou
pela mão e me levou na escola para
ganhar uma bolsa
porque só estudando com uma bolsa numa
escola privada eu poderia realizar o
sonho da menina pobre que queria ser
advogada o jornalista disseram pro meu
pai
o boletim dela é muito bom ela parece
ter um excelente desempenho é falante
simpática mas ela não vai ganhar a bolsa
na minha cabeça bolsa era um acessório
cheio de borboletas flores
eu já estava me imaginando saindo da
escola bolsa mas bolsa era a
oportunidade do pobre estudar onde ele
não pode pagar e como meu pai havia sido
contra na política anterior ao candidato
que aquela escola apoiava foi dita meu
pai é
lá não poderá ter bolsa negada bolsa eu
fui fazer o magistério e briguei com os
meus professores de didática que já
compreendeu num lugar que a escola era o
centro de ensino que ensina ignorar e aí
a minha professora de didática disse vão
para as escolas aonde vocês vão estagiar
e lá faça uma espécie de sondagem
veja o que é preciso fazer eu fui e
observei que a escola onde eu iria
estagiar era no distrito
sem água não tinha vidros buracos no
teto e no chão numa periferia
extremamente pobre
voltei para a sala de aula e falei pro
esse é o retrato da sala e ela disse
mackay cobrar enfeite para que ninguém
veja
que lição dolorosa e que forma
interessante de ratificar a fala do
poeta então é uma criança não tínhamos
condições econômicas pedimos cartaz
emprestados e conseguimos doação de um
papel metro e fizemos toda a maquiagem
que aquela sala precisava e que o
estágio do magistério e pedir a e aí
estamos lá organizando tudo isso entra
na sala de aula no tempo das vacas
magras toda vestida de fada de estágio
bom dia gente tudo bem e o que foi que
houve crianças pobres com a tinhas aos
pés das cadeiras
perguntei queridos vocês estão com as
suas latinhas é para fazer lembrança não
pro é para levar o resto da comida pra
casa
nossos irmãos não estudam então não
comem mas nesse cenário a onde eu maquia
ea realidade para apresentar um estágio
a realidade
gritou mais forte e me ensinou ali que
eu poderia não apagar os retratos em
preto e branco eu poderia não ter
condições de sanar a fome daqueles
meninos eu poderia talvez jamais deixá
los em condições de enfrentar o mundo
dignamente
mas ali eu prometi que o sol que eles
viam quando entrava só seria fiz a
promessa de que a onde eu estivesse como
professora e
seria em cantante através da palavra
ainda que o cenário não permitisse eu
daria conta de dar oferecer promover
organizar uma educação com sentido e
desde então esse é o meu objetivo como
educadora aprendi desde cedo desde o
limiar desse tempo de magistério
aprendi que não adianta ensinar sobre
senzala' pela união à escravidão se o
meu aluno não dar conta de reconhecer um
negro como indivíduo ao seu lado
aprendi que assim como as escolas se
esmeram ensinar os fenótipos dos bichos
de nada adianta se o menino arrancar o
couro do gato vivo e jogar sal na pele
do sapo não houve sentido se ele não
entender que animais precisam de
proteção
aprendi que se eu ensinar seu aluno que
uma molécula superior é capaz de
destruir um impedir o composto um
detergente limpam a gordura não é
significativo
se os meus alunos não entenderem que
tarefas domésticas não foram feitas só
para mulheres e que mesas aonde as
louças chegam limpas e saem sujas são
espaços de debate construção convivência
e comunhão
após 35 anos como docente nas redes
pública e privada
aprendi que as escolas não precisam ser
destruídas mas os seus muros precisam
ser transpostos porquê porque a escola
insiste como foi dito em diferentes
falas nessa noite a escola insiste em
ignorar a escola insiste em camuflar a
escola insiste em não ver ensinar aquilo
que cabe no território de disputas que
ela se tornou ela é o lugar onde o
estado realiza suas promessas
era o lugar dos currículos realizam suas
deficiências é um lugar onde as famílias
demonstram os seus limites é um lugar
onde os professores se esmeram para
passar os seus saberes
ela é o lugar onde os jovens se só são
para sonhar
aprendi que escolas não são
fábricas alunos não são objetos
conteúdos de ensino precisam ter
significado o mundo existirá
independente da escola as políticas
públicas não dão conta das dores que ela
tem
aprendi escolas não modificam sociedades
escolas afetam indivíduos fi afetados
serão capazes de alterar as realidades e
formar mundos um dia eu levantei a mão e
fiz uma pergunta a professora e ela me
tirou da sala e chamou a minha mãe e
disse vamos cortar as asinhas de gláucia
as minhas asas estão aqui
se você olhar atentamente para vê las
mas só são capazes de ver as minhas asas
quem as tem e você o que aprendeu
apesar da escola espero sinceramente que
uma das lições tenha sido mantém asas
vivas ea segunda com as suas asas
sobrevoe duras
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]